so how do we go from this
to this yes that's right it's time to go
outside and flow in the cold weather
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to share with you
some of my secrets for bundling up for
flowing Outdoors during the winter now
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
paquonen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so let's be real flowing when it
gets cold out is kind of a bummer you
have the option to either flow indoors
and deal with a really cramped space or
you can bundle up to go outside and
you'll also lose a little bit of
Mobility there now none of these are
particularly good options but if we want
to keep our flow going during the cold
months we have to embrace some of them
so I'm going to do a series here talking
about the different ways that we can
make that happen starting today with how
I bundle up when I'm going outside to
flow when it is cold out today it is in
the 40s here in DC which I realize is
not that cold compared to many other
places but it's cold for me what can I
say my ancestors came from above the
Arctic Circle but somehow the
epigenetics just did not work out for me
now I don't have long johns or anything
like that but I do have a couple under
layers that I really like to use so I
will go ahead and share them with you
first and foremost is this really
awesome polar Max shirt it is made of
some form of synthetic so I try and
avoid this one I'm going to be spinning
fire but if I'm just going to be
spinning with like my sock pull your
contact POI it's a great option I also
still do the 90s style of putting the
long sleeve underneath the short sleeve
if so give me just one second to switch
those around
so what I like about using under layers
like this is that they're pretty Sleek
like my biggest priority here is trying
to hold on to freedom of movement as
much as possible there's a ton of
options out there for making us warm but
those that allow us to stay warm as well
as allowing us freedom of movement are a
little bit rarer and this approach
definitely holds on to that value next
up we are going to add my favorite
sweater I cannot remember when or where
I got this it's by Dockers it is really
really really warm it's cotton and nylon
again I don't wear this with fire but it
does give me another layer of protection
out there in the cold so let's put that
on
[Music]
all right cool so next up let's talk
about bottoms so this is a trick that I
picked up when I was still doing dance
lessons regularly I noticed a lot of
dancers who would wear multiple layers
of pants now my bottom layer here is
just going to be these Adidas track
pants that I have held onto forever and
a day these are at least a decade old
and they've seen better days but they're
really really good at locking in heat
and blocking out the wind which those
are two very very important things for
me in the winter for the top layer I
usually like to have something that's a
little bit heavier a material this is a
set of cargo pants from Union Bay and
the thing I like most about these is
that they work both over the track pants
as well as just by themselves they have
a slim enough fit that I can wear them
day to day but they also have enough
room that I can wear them over the track
pants and it doesn't look too out of the
ordinary so let me put these on
foreign
[Music]
all right so next up let's talk about
the top layer for my top so I usually
like to go with hoodies because well I'm
a hoodie guy and usually they're pretty
sleek and are good for freedom of
movement so these are my two go-to's uh
this one right here on my left is
actually a travel hoodie from bowbox
it's a little tight in the shoulders I
didn't get exactly the right size so
this tends to be the one that I use a
little bit less but the thing that it's
really good at is uh it's a great
windbreaker and so if it's super windy
outside this is what I want to go with
in most cases though I go with this
hoodie that I got from Tibetan gift
exchange in hate Ashbury in San
Francisco and as you can see it has seen
a lot of better days and it's been
patched many times but what I like about
it number one is I think it looks cool
number two is that the inside layer here
is fleece so it is way warmer than it
actually looks there's plenty of pocket
space in here and also just you know
sentimental value this has been with me
forever and it's kind of like an old
friend at this point so it's not super
windy outside today I'm going to go with
this option
cool so next up I have plenty of
different winter hats but the one that
is kind of my Nuclear option is this
that I got one winter up in Boston it is
extraordinarily fluffy on the inside it
is one of the warmest hats that I have
ever owned and it sure
does do the trick so I've also kind of
become legendary for my mask usage in
the past couple years and one of my
great discoveries in doing so is that
masks are also really really good for
dealing with the cold so I actually tend
to wear these pretty frequently not just
because I think I might go to the
grocery store to grab something after
I'm done flowing but also because it
just keeps my face warm outside and I
kind of like that so let's add that
shall we
all right so now let's talk gloves I
have two different sets that I use
regularly one of which is a little bit
Slimmer and a little bit sleeker these
are the ones that I tend to use during
the Spring and fall they're really
really nice because they're pretty close
to just having bare hands and I really
like the texture on them I can actually
do Gunslingers in these which is
fantastic they are made by looks like
agent and I have a thicker set that I
use during the winter months that are
better when it gets colder and because
we're in the 40s today I'm gonna go with
the thicker set they are made by ankier
I'll link to all these things in the
description all right friends I think
I'm finally ready to go outside and flow
care to join me
excuse
me
[Music]
thank you
hey friends so I am back indoors now and
warm again which is amazing and I think
I'm going to call this one a success now
you might have noticed that at a certain
point I actually got too warm and I
actually shut a layer which is fine by
me because I would rather be too warm
than too cold and this was unanticipated
but I was actually so bundled up that I
felt safe doing ground work out there on
the asphalt which I never ever ever do
that in the summer so that was kind of a
cool Discovery even though now I'm
thinking the choreography that I was
working on I have committed myself to
doing that and we're going to have to
see how that works out in the long term
but either way thanks for coming along
with me on this Voyage what are your
favorite tips for spinning outside
during the colder months please leave me
a comment and let me know and if you got
anything out of this video please leave
a like comment share and subscribe to
help other people find it to keep the
conversation going and of course to help
my channel grow
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helps make this video and all the videos
on this channel possible thank you one
and all for your very very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter and you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards as well as helping me
out in my mission to try and bring POI
spinning and flow Arts to The Wider
world so go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
more Vlogs that I've done in a variety
of aspects of flow Arts culture I will
go ahead and leave a link to a playlist
of them down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you will like this top video
right here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get outside and flow today bundle up for
it and I will see you with a new video
very soon
peace